please welcome Christopher Walken kevin
kline Cuba Gooding jr. Alan Arkin and
Joel Grey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
actors actor this is a term that
describes someone who continuously
pushes himself and his art deeper and
deeper with little fanfare and a driving
commitment to the truth would have put
it more simply seymour philip hoffman in
doubt in doubt philip plays father Flynn
a role that requires the audience to
constantly question what is true and
what's not true fortunately for us
Philip your commitment to the truth in
every moment keeps us exactly where we
should be unsettled unsure and
enthralled in our uncertainty for that
again this year we sing your praises
last year's winner of this award
one for traipsing through the desert on
a demonic path to shoot and kill our
next nominee so there is a certain
justice in speaking tonight about Josh
Brolin's brilliant work in milk actors
have been known to look for roles that
show them as strong and morally tough
but as Dan White Josh you took on the
role of someone who acts out of fear and
weakness
thus reminding us that we must replace
fear with understanding and turn
weakness into strength
oh you really nailed it well I agree
with everything that's been said so far
absolutely absolutely
now let's talk about taking risks shall
we Robert Downey jr. this year with iron
man and this nominated stroke of genius
and Tropic Thunder you've put yourself
back among the boldest and best actors
working today to be a white actor to be
a white actor playing a white Australian
actor playing a black man in blackface
I'll say it are you out of your mind
I mean you know I can understand getting
into your character for the art of the
character so but that's enough I'm
taking the parts from the black people
man the brothers need to work you know
that's enough of that I appreciate it
yes congratulations on your nomination
and your upcoming production on
principal photography of your new film
shaft Michael Shannon is a wonderful
actor and has been so in many movies
over the last decade in Revolutionary
Road he got everyone's attention for
sure but a man with no filter between
what he thinks and what he says
every actor aims for the truth in their
work and playing a character who reveals
what's unsaid beneath the conventional
exterior Michael you are right on target
well done
in a year of striking film images
perhaps the most unforgettable was that
of a man with his face smeared in clown
makeup lethally sticking his head out of
a speeding car relishing the night wind
and reveling in the chaos he has
unleashed on the streets of Gotham City
menacing mercurial droll and diabolical
Heath Ledger as the Joker in the Dark
Knight kept us all on edge anxious to
see what act of appalling mischief he
might commit next with this preview of
performance as well as with a wide range
of other roles to which he put his
unique signature Heath Ledger has left
us an original and enduring legacy
and the Oscar goes to Heath Ledger in
the dark
[Music]
[Applause]
the Oscar on behalf of Heath Ledger are
his father Kim Leger his mother Sally
Bell and his sister Kate Leger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all I have to say this is ever
so humbling just being amongst such
wonderful people in such a wonderful
industry firstly we'd like to thank the
Academy for recognizing our son's
amazing work Warner Brothers and
Christopher Nolan in particular for
allowing Heath the creative license to
develop and explore this crazy
Joker character to Steve Alexander
Keith's mentor special friend an agent
for ten years
we love you Steve this award tonight
would have humbly validated Heath quiet
determination to be truly accepted by
you all here his peers within an
industry he so loved thank you
Heath was such a compassionate and
generous soul who added so much
excitement and inspiration to our lives
we have been truly overwhelmed by the
honour and respect being bestowed upon
him with this award tonight we are
choosing to celebrate and be happy for
what he has achieved
Heath we both knew what you had created
in the joka was extraordinarily special
and had even talked about being here on
this very day we really wish you were
but we proudly accept this award on
behalf of your beautiful Mathilda
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]